أجنبي
نقوم بممر بريء ،
لدينا الحق في القيام بذلك وفقًا
للقواعد الدولية واتفاقية الأمم المتحدة
لقانون البحار سفينة خفر السواحل الروسية
هذه سفينة حربية بريطانية دلتا 36
نواياك المناورة غير واضحة
اطلب سرعة الدورة التدريبية
ونوايا المرور  بسبب
العبادة البريطانية ، فأنا روسي
إذا لم تغير مسارك إلى حرب النجوم ،
فسأطرد ،
سأكون حريقًا ، لا تعبر خط الحدود ،
هل تقرأني على سفينة حربية بريطانية ،
تدخل سفينتك
البحر الإقليمي للتكوين الروسي
يجب أن تغادر على الفور
بحر الاتحاد الروسي المربوط.لدي
نيران مدفعية
في هذه المنطقة ،
ولا يتحمل الاتحاد الروسي أي مسؤولية إذا كانت سفينتك
ستلحق الضرر
بالمنطقة المهددة بالانقراض ،
نعم
هذه سفينة حربية بريطانية دلتا
3-6 سأستمر في اتباع المسار
المعترف به دوليًا
9-0 في المياه الدولية الوطنية
هو ما